in der letzten folge als yvonne
horisberger begleitet gleich zwei
patienten im rega ambulanzjet nach hause
der angehende flugkapitän philipp sémon
wird von seinen bienen angegriffen
zwangspause ihn beförderungs prozess
kann er seinen prüfungs flug antreten
die sechsjährige anouk ist gestürzt
vermutlich hat sie innere verletzungen
pilot rick maurer fliegt sie zur
überwachung ins inselspital in bern der
ambulanzjet der rega ist soeben in
zürich gelandet
im cockpit pilot philipp 7 nach dem
unglücklichen bienenstich ist er wieder
einsatzfähig und konnte seinen prüfungs
flug antreten hat er bestanden
[Musik]
jetzt hat philips ihm in den rang eines
kapitäns billiges streben eine gegangen
übertriebene simulator unter strom flüge
immer unter beobachtung dass die auf
eine wohngebäude tage erlebt man nur
einmal ins innere vor das gleiche
[Musik]
während dj crew im hangar des rega
center feiert er steht ja
einsatzzentrale bei gitti kuhn
hochbetrieb
ein einsatz im napfgebiet patrick maurer
und seine kruse in den wenigen minuten
starten
reformen sollten sich vorgenommen
auch einsatzleiter rené kuhn kennen die
einzelheiten noch nicht
nach der extrem bei die bewusstlosen
vermutlich sind mutter und tochter wegen
gülle gas ohnmächtig geworden bei einem
rega-helikopter nur eine person liegend
transportiert werden kann hat die
zentrale in diesem fall neben rega drei
aus belp auch reger 10 aus wilderswil
aufgeboten
reger 3 ist von eingetroffen und schnell
wird klar dass beide ärzte gefordert
sind mutter und kind werden sofort
künstlich beatmet es ist unglaublich
lange die patientinnen bewusstlos im
stall lagen und die giftigen dämpfe der
gülle einige die tochter ist schon
bereit für den abflug
aber noch muss für beide patientinnen
ein spitalbett organisiert werden
inzwischen nimmt das team von regazzoni
die bewusstlose mutter an bord
platz tritt für mehr klingt gott nicht
gläubig es ist okay okay oder
bei dem open gewann
[Musik]
autobauer
inselspital bern hier wird mutter
tochter versorgt
eigentlich unter sich jetzt eigentlich
bebenburg seit sonntag nicht mehr
sprechen jetzt bringe man sie einfach
eigentlich magazin kehrt zurück nach
wilders wie notarzt romy von wien hat
die patientinnen spezialisten übergeben
dass gerade frauen darum flur gewesen
jetzt neurologisches das heißt von ropa
dass das ganze bestand und auch intensiv
station habe mich nur auf kleidung huber
und den versuchten sie lachen und hofft
dass sie dass sie das mit cannes oder
mac wenig sagen schade noch bestimmt
später wird romy von widerfahren mutter
und tochter laden noch tagelang im
spital
sie haben den unfall aber ohne bleibende
schäden überstanden
[Musik]
der nächste fall für verdacht auf
hirnhautentzündung bei einem kind nein
das geht über die sich herum dass das
zahlt die versicherung er hat ja die
krankenkosten das geht normalerweise
wird die versicherung sind sie bei uns
mitglied gönnerin ja ja dann müssen sie
sich sowieso keine sorgen machen
die rega verrechnet jeden einsatz der
krankenkasse oder unfallversicherung des
patienten weiter ob gönner oder nicht
und dann ist er quasi administrativ die
rieger erlässt den gönnern die differenz
falls die versicherung nicht alle kosten
deckt im letzten jahr hat sie so 10
millionen franken übernommen
das ist knapp ein neuntel der gesamten
gönner gelder
das ganze sicher schnupfen war heute mit
micon herstellt bietet vielleicht von
der eth uns darum konzert das man
trickst würde die chemiefirma bücher und
das sehr ordentlich laufen intensiv
pflegefachfrau yvonne horisberger und
kathi cortez fliegen heute nach italien
mit
charlie dass da hinten aufmachen sagte
domenica schimmel gardine denke dass sie
demnächst schon zu früher stunde genau
fest aus dem markt erschließen flugangst
genauso gut die dead kugelt einen
patienten abholen der nach einem
verkehrsunfall schwer verletzt im spital
liegt verletzt worden
und mit gut weil der jet ohnehin nach
italien fliegt nimmt die rega ein
vierjähriges mädchen mit dass an den
folgen eines schleudertraumas leidet
im cockpit nimmt philipp sémon zum
ersten mal auf der linken seite platz
freunde jetzt natürlich eine anti
fluglehrer und der wachstumstrend ist
eine belastung über twitter blog wird
und jedes komma jeder punkt korrigiert
wird an das nötig ist
das nimmt er voll und
[Musik]
inselspital bern
judith iris vom sozial- und
betreuungsdienst erreger zu besuch bei
familie die sechsjährige anouk ist vor
vier tagen bäuchlings auf eine stange
gefallen
diagnose milzriss wegen innerer
blutungen musste die rega sie rasch vom
spital frutigen hierher verlegen
ist das auf der intensivstation sind
hätte ich das für mich gespielt auch sie
eigentlich jetzt die preisträger und
schön zum knoten weiter mit nur eine
kleine ruse gesagt war durch vorgaben
ganz genau so die studie
weißt du noch marina gott bitte mir
liegt ob das wahlweise sich dann machst
du dich mach ich nicht wohin das geld
habe ich nur nen anderen haben
aber tiergarten alles erklären
calvin geflogen sind und wo welche ja
das nur gut die möglichkeit einfach so
rundum der helikopter mit einer sache
mit dem kind reden und erzähle aber nun
ist auf dem weg zur besserung in den
nächsten acht wochen wird sie aber
wieder rennen noch tun dürfen
der riss muss verheilen es macht sich
auf zu weiteren reha patienten die
allenfalls betreuung brauchen
die helikopter von reger 10 aus
wilderswil fliegt das rega center an
pilot rick maurer bringt seine maschine
zur inspektion
alle 200 flugstunden steht ein solcher
check an
als board system check macht jackpot der
aufwand für die wartung der helikopter
ist beträchtlich auf eine flugstunde
kommen im schnitt drei stunden
unterhaltung
naja also dass da schon wenn ihr meine
roadcross feststellung nicht so hohe
dichte sie sehen auf mehr auch wenn sie
das so sehen
um die vertraue insofern dass seine
truppe wieder deutlich was uns hoffen
morales seinen helikopter im rega center
zurück
gleich zu verzog und arbeitsmarkt
sport
der helikopter von reger 10 wird zerlegt
es ist einer von 17 reger maschinen die
hier regelmäßig gewartet werden
[Musik]
es ist schon bald müssen sich die
luftfahrzeug mechaniker mit einem neuen
typ helikopter vertraut machen
die rega lässt in italien für 50
millionen franken drei neue maschinen
bauen der rega ambulanzjet ist in
italien gelandet
und die erste patientin wartet schon die
kleine inder leidet an den folgen eines
schleudertraumas sie hat nackenschmerzen
immer wieder nasenbluten und wirkte
zeitweise apathisch die eltern haben
angst dass sich hinter den symptomen
schlimmes verbirgt
sie müssen etwas war das ist nicht
schlimm
wir sind froh dass wir zurück in die
schweiz können
[Musik]
vom flughafen geht es in die innenstadt
ins spital wurde der verunfallte patient
liegt
[Musik]
wir müssen auf die intensivstation
ich weiß nicht ob es im dritten stock
eine intensivstation hat sie können da
vorne fragen was ist jetzt immer noch
funde und da muss man nicht viel
geworden
[Musik]
das war nur ein intensiv station im
spital hat einen sieg
hinten links erster stock wer das wir
kommen aus der schweiz
wir holen den schweizer partie
vielleicht sind sie auf der falschen
intensivstation
es ist ein schwer verletzter patient sie
ihren sich er ist nicht hier ist einfach
dass das vorzeichen sind nicht geplant
die rega ist im auftrag einer
versicherung unterwegs und die hat die
adresse der klinik falsch angegeben
neue klinik weiter versuchen mein name
ist von doch ich bin vor der regel
zusammen mit frage ist wer gehören sieht
schweiz zurückfliegen
mit instituts zurück bringen sich und
schlafe während dem ganzen flug haben
sie das verstanden sowie 40 wird sind
alles gut
mein name ist im anhang mit dem report
auch verbraucht und stoff da dürfen wir
schauen uns gut mit dem zdf programm zum
laufen
und auch hier noch in flüge nicht gut
[Musik]
euro
reger pilot rick maurer ist inzwischen
hoch in der luft er arbeitet heute für
seinen ehemaligen arbeitgeber us
helikopter ein kommerzielles unternehmen
es geht auf den niesen
[Musik]
etwa einmal pro monat leisten trick
maurer einen solchen einsatz als
fliegerisches training
die rega gibt die ihn im rahmen eines
abkommens mit der partnerorganisation
zwischen copter frei
25 mal geht es mit teer auf den niesen
tag ist durchgeplant
[Musik]
das anziehen rega heli hat der pilot
durch ein ausgebuchtes fenster sicht
auch die fläche unter der maschine
mehr
[Musik]
neun jahre lang hat erik maurer vor
seiner zeit bei der rega als transport
pilot und luftfahrzeug mechaniker
gearbeitet
kurze pausen bieten bei dieser arbeit
nur die tankstopps die zeit drängt
jede minute kostet den auftraggeber
knochenarbeit für flughelfer und den
piloten
mit sport natürlich dazu ein regal und
das spüre ich dass auch ein abkommen
soll aber nicht später macht aber umso
mehr probiert man sich mit ska und sonst
völlig immer das bundesgebiet
auf diese auftrags flüge möchte maurer
auf keinen fall verzichten wäre möglich
da kennt der frische kapital soll frauen
vor allem die kabel situationen einen
namen machte mitternacht habe ich jetzt
also von mir hilft der weiße aber auf
die auch bei millionen von bis zu 33
mit vollem tank geht es zum nächsten
auftrag
holztransport aus einem eigenheim im
kandertal
die leitungen sind eine tödliche gefahr
wenn
[Musik]
gegen 70 rotationen beträgt an diesem
tag fliegen
[Musik]
rega center am flughafen zürich
art tommy von will von reger 10 in
wilderswil steht heute als instruktor im
einsatz
er wird jungen berufskollegen das
einmaleins der winden rettung bringen
acht anästhesisten und intensivmediziner
treten heute ihre stelle bei der rege an
sie werden für sechs bis acht monate als
sogenannte rotation setzen auf den basen
arbeiten speziell ein großer moment
die nervosität steigt die neuen ärzte
wurden aus vielen bewerbern ausgewählt
es geht nicht nur um die medizinischen
fähigkeiten
sie müssen auch gebirgs tauglich und
teamfähig sein
[Gelächter]
nach einem theorie block geht es jetzt
in die praxis
fertig
[Musik]
wenn der patient bringen
wenn sie selbstbewusst ist nicht so
schön ruhig war nie windet und das land
zur körpererfahrung ist rechts stress
denn problemlos funk und sagte hey ich
kann nur zwei minuten schneller finden
schweiz liegt und wie gehen sie weg
gemacht ein symbol der vielleicht deren
toxische länder die cdu nein ich finde
das braucht noch niederstraßer los hier
gibt es tempo vor
[Musik]
die csu zitiert werden wieder los die
bringen die freilich brauchen
die instruktion
je nach bauart das macht man es mehr
oder weniger frauen die weniger häufig
machen und berlinale vertriebsleute mit
kleidern aus doch dann meistens und
musste die handgriffe und einfach
korrekt machen und richtig heimisch
gewesen war
die hainstraße kurt da nicht die axt an
[Applaus]
die erste instruktion ist fast
überstanden
in einer woche gilt es ernst scharfes
winden training am berg
die maschine von swiss helikopter landet
um erneut aufzutanken
reger patrick maurer hat einen langen
tag hinter sich
ein letzter auftrag steht noch an
jetzt kommen zwei touristinnen werden
sich mit den profis in die tiefe stürzen
[Musik]
zurück zu rega crew in italien
sie hat den patienten in den ambulanzjet
gebracht das flugzeug wird zur
intensivstation
[Musik]
die vierjährige in ihrer hat im chat
gewartet es geht hier schon sichtlich
besser die rega hat sie so gesetzt dass
sie den anderen patienten nicht sieht
[Applaus]
denkst du noch im dunkeln
ja super widerruf der wohl mein name ist
heute im moment nicht reden
das versuchen
juli mit
das noch der passende song happy farm
zurück nicht geschlafen
karlsruhe
die jungs gemacht mit dem exkurs
netzwerks grad
[Musik]
wir sind auf eine sehr starke maschine
jasid ausläuft
die rega würde patienten in der schweiz
in ein zentrumsspital bringen
im cockpit die zeichnung der kleinen
patienten
[Musik]
elia wird sich in der schweiz genauer
untersuchen lassen müssen nach zwei
tagen der angst kommen die eltern zur
ruhe
[Musik]
politisches und so war für die sich
verringert das menü drücken
[Musik]
heimbilanz 7 2 sind ziel ein
wir würden gern so schnell wie möglich
landen
[Musik]
landung in der heimat
die ambulanzen stehen schon bereit den
schwerverletzten patienten wird die rega
noch ins kantonsspital vergleichen was
hier noch niemand weiß er wird seinen
verkehrsunfall nicht überleben
[Musik]
rightnow kanton aargau hier lebt yvonne
horisberger hier kommen sie zur ruhe
seit 13 jahren arbeitet die flight neues
für die rega und immer wieder erlebt sie
bei der arbeit schwere momente
sie schaut wichtig dass man dass man
sagt wilk abgrenzt und bevor man mit
crewmitglied ritz betreten mit pilates
überkommen das natürlich mit und für so
wichtig dass sie das wirklich verstehen
was sitzt daher geld oder die stange mit
dem patient und besitzt der mensch ist
stolz mit dem team über das heck retten
und das ist ja auch nicht schlimm also
ich finde dass wenn man das heißt so
hoch ist berger lebt zusammen mit 19
hasen und kaninchen und vier katzen
15 janina wichtig bin daheim ist
eigentlich ist auch kurz stand irgendwie
weiß ja was ist mit kennt sich eben
die summe ist also sich das mancher der
klassische stil irgendwo rum ist die
flight neues in der luft betreuen ihre
wohn partnerin und die nachbarn die
vielen tiere
ja ja nie erträumt seiner bruderschaft
habe sich gut
wir haben uns das gut finden
man muss nicht so bleiben
[Musik]
rega basis bern belp heute ist tommy von
vielen nicht in wilderswil sondern
hierbei rega drei stationiert danke dass
du den 8
tommy von will hat einen einsatz als in
struktur und coach er beurteilt die
abläufe bei reger 3 und das wissen und
können der crew ein check nennt sich
diese überprüfe matthias hatte liegt mit
bunten fähnchen beurteilen warum das
ganze team norden und statistisch
sondern zusätzlich von medizinischen
bestätigt
[Musik]
eine so genannte primäre aus einem
unfall mit einem traktor wie sie nicht
mehr fertig vom riskieren
ok
ziel ist cairns im kanton aufhalten
jetzt noch schnell herum
in der nächsten sendung warum ist dieser
traktor auf abwege gekommen und wie geht
es dem fahrer außerdem die crew des rega
ambulanzjet mit pilot philip simon roth
auf mallorca einen muskel kranken
patienten den arm gebrochen hat
und schwierige bergung schwieriger 10
ein kletterer ist 20 meter ins tal
gestürzt
natürlich geblieben
[Musik]